Namo tassa bhagavato arahato samma sambuddhasa Namo tassa bhagavato arahato samma sambuddhasa Namo tassa bhagavato arahato samma sambuddhasa Homage to the Buddha, the Blessed, Noble,
and fully self-awakened one you're going to translate that for us oh okay so i i'm going to start off with just a little um
talk about the Buddha and war.
So the first is to, you know, make a distinction between pacifism and nonviolence.
So pacifism.
Wait, wait, wait, wait.
Sorry.
Go on.
Vorrei parlare brevemente a proposito della guerra e della differenza tra, sorry, pacifism and nonviolence.
Non-violence.
So pacifism is an ideology.
And ideologies like communism and neoliberalism always work on some sort of idea of how things ought to be.
And therefore they lose connection with what's actually happening.
And as Marx
said about capitalism, it has the seeds of its own destruction.
So you can say that of any ideology.
Non-violence is an attitude.
It's a way of relating to all being.
While non-violence is an attitude, a way of relating to all beings.
There are several stories that have been told about the Buddha who came into contact with war.
The first one is an argument between the Sakians, his own people, and the people on the other side of the river, the Coleans.
So there was this discussion between the Sakians, who were the people, his own people, and those who lived on the other side of the river.
And this argument over water rights was moving towards a war between the two tribes.
So the Buddha
heard about it maybe, but he went up there to try and help with the rights of the water.
And he basically asked them what was more precious, the water in the river or the blood in their veins?
Sostanzialmente chiese loro che cosa fosse più prezioso, se fosse più preziosa l'acqua nel fiume oppure il sangue nelle loro vene.
Well, that brought them to the table and they were able to discuss the situation calmly and the problem disappeared.
Quindi questo fece sì che si decidessero a sedersi intorno a un tavolo per discutere
Now there was a more serious situation with Viduddha Bhat.
So he was the son of Passenadi.
And Passenadi was a very committed supporter of the Buddha.
So the Viduddha wanted to marry into the Sakya.
and the son wanted to marry the Sakya tribe.
The Sakya were already vassals to the king of Kosala.
They were subjects.
The Sakya were vassals to the king of Kosala.
And so he married one of the Sakyan princesses.
However, he came to know that in fact she wasn't a princess at all, but belonged to the lowest of all the castes.
Well, he was very angry, so he got his army together to go and destroy the Saccions.
He had his elephants and his cavalry, his chariots and his infantry.
When the Buddha heard this, he went to see him.
And when the Buddha came to know about it, he went to find him.
Now, we don't know what the Buddha said to him, but I would think it was along the lines of this is not going to create good karma for you.
We don't know exactly what the Buddha said, what he told him, but I have the impression that he must have told him something like, I know that this will not go much in favor of your positive karma.
So Viduddha took his advice and went home.
No sooner had he got home than he got angry again and got back on his elephant.
So the Buddha appeared again and seemed to have convinced him to turn back.
As soon as he got back, he got angry and he got back on his elephant.
Again, the Buddha came and again convinced him that this was not a good idea, so he went back home.
E di nuovo la stessa cosa comparvi il Buddha che lo convinse a tornare a casa che non era affatto una buona idea.
But unfortunately as soon as he got home he got angry and he got back on his elephant.
Ma appena tornò a casa si arrabbiò nuovamente e risali sugli elefanti.
This time when they asked the Buddha to go again he says it's not going to work, he's committed.
So it would seem that he destroyed the capital of the Sakyas, Kapilavatthu.
Probably the Sakyans ran off into the jungle for a while.
And they set up another capital city.
Seemingly, you can actually visit them.
One is in India and one is in Nepal.
The final example is to do with Ajatasattu.
Ajatasattu was the son of Bimbisara, the king of Magadha.
He was the son of Bimbisara, king of the Mandaka.
In the same way, Bimbisara had been a very good supporter of the Buddha, but his son just didn't have the same commitment.
Similarly, he was a great supporter of the Buddha, but not his son.
In fact, Ajatasattu starved his poor old father to death.
Anzi, Ajatasattu fece morire di fame il padre.
He locked him in a little room which they say you can still see in Rajgir.
Si dice che l'abbia chiuso in una stanzetta che si dovrebbe poter vedere
What's the name again?
In una città.
Yeah, Rajgir.
Rajgir.
Yeah.
It was a small building, excuse me, away from the palace.
Era un piccolo edificio poco lontano dal palazzo.
Now, he wanted to conquer the Vajji Confederacy.
E voleva conquistare la Confederazione dei Vajji.
And the peculiar thing is that he sent his chief minister to ask the Buddha whether it was the best time to do so.
Now the Buddha, of course, won't tell anybody what to do.
All he does is point to principles and you are left to make the decision.
Now what he did was to describe the qualities of a strong community.
Sorry, he described?
The qualities that keep a community strong.
Right, sorry.
Sì, quello che fece fu di descrivere quali erano le qualità di una comunità forte.
And he was really talking about the monastics, the monks and nuns.
In realtà stava parlando proprio della comunità monastica.
So Vassacaro and the king assumed that he was hinting that the Vagis were a strong people.
So he didn't attack them.
He sent in the CIA.
And in order to bribe and set one people against another.
And when the time was right, he went in with his army to keep the peace.
Ah, e al momento opportuno entrò con tutto il suo esercito per riportare la pace che, peraltro, la guerra che aveva lui stesso procurato.
So, some writers say that the Buddha would support a defensive war.
Alcuni commentatori dicono che il Buddha avrebbe sostenuto, avrebbe appoggiato una guerra di tipo difensivo.
But there's no indication in the scriptures that he either encouraged or discouraged anybody from war as such.
And he was in a
he was in a tricky position.
Because the monks and nuns had spread throughout the whole of North India.
If he had supported one king against the other, then you can imagine all the people in the king he didn't, all the monks and nuns in the territory of the king he did not support would be kicked out.
The problem was that if he had supported one of the kings or one of the kingdoms, the monks and nuns who lived in the areas that did not have his support,
Now, this does make the Buddha sound, it does sound a little cynical of the Buddha.
But he was grounded in reality, realpolitik.
So there must have been some concern about the monks and nuns.
But I think the main thing is that he never told people what to do.
He was only concerned with getting across those principles that are necessary to bring suffering to an end.
What really interested him was to communicate those principles that could allow suffering to cease.
So I can only presume that when the question of war came up, it was always pointing to that person and saying, if you go to war, you will create bad karma for yourself.
So I think that when a person was asking himself
Because it's very difficult to kill another human being unless you have aversion in the heart.
Now we have the example of the Shaolin Kung Fu monks in China.
We have the example of the Shaolin monks, monks who practice Kung Fu in China.
So in China, if the emperor didn't like Buddhists, they would be persecuted, and the next emperor would like Buddhists and they were okay.
What happened in China was that if an emperor didn't love the monks, the Buddhists would persecute them, and who, while perhaps a subsequent sovereign,
So the Shaolin monks began to develop a form of fighting which was defensive.
Not to be overcome by aversion towards the enemy.
This ethos went into Japan from China.
And it became part of the samurai code.
So the samurai were warriors.
Samurai were warriors.
And there is a story where a samurai had beaten his opponent, had lifted the sword to cut him in two and then walked away.
Sorry, I didn't get that.
What happened?
There was a point where a samurai defeated his opponent.
He had raised his sword to cut him in two.
But then walked away.
Ma poi invece se ne andorono.
And when they asked him why he'd walked away, he said, I was angry.
E quando gli chiesero perché te ne sei andato, lui rispose, ero arrabbiato.
So when it comes to considering what our personal relationship is to war, remember that
That is our personal relationship to war.
It's not the Buddha's.
And all the Buddha would say to you, if you were to ask him, is, you know, can you kill somebody without aversion in your heart?
And if you do kill someone with aversion in your heart, then that will bring unwholesome results for yourself.
So, of course, this is not a very straightforward decision between black and white.
If you're defending your family, defending the country, then, of course, that particular motivation may be greater than getting rid of the aversion in your heart.
Certainly, if you find yourself having to defend your family or your country,
And it's left to the individual to decide how they feel or understand they ought to behave.
I can only hope my words have been of some assistance.
that I have not caused greater confusion and that by careful decision-making you will find your way to complete liberation from suffering.
and that with an attentive reflection and application you can find the way to liberation that brings you complete liberation.